have unwavering passion to help which
means it's going to come with some pain
it's your [__] fault who the [__]
wants to hear that
no one
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
[Music]
what do you think about when apps just
straight up copy each other example
Clapper looks just like tiktok Burger
King looks like McDonald's
Adidas looks like Nike two-year-old
looks like Ford nature of business life
you look like a BMX hipster you're a
reference
we are
good morning good morning how are you
good morning morning good to see you
good morning what I want to do is like
have as much interaction with everyone
as possible
foreign
how do I feel I feel good when I walk
into this office and I watch that people
are like actually enjoying interacting
with each other I feel very strongly
that we're heading in the right
direction on that front I want you to
enjoy your days more and I want our
business to grow more that's why it's
required for us to be Vayner not like
the rest of the industry I'm just very
inspired by who we are and I'm very
passionate about our culture I'm very
passionate about the honey Empire stuff
I'm passionate about kind Candor I want
to build an enormous company so that
everyone looks up to us because if they
look up to us then they have to copy us
and if they copy us that means they have
to be nice to each other how many people
here have worked at another agency raise
your hand
great how many people feel like this is
a nicer company than the one they used
to work for raise your hand
that inspires the [__] out of me thank
you
[Music]
I'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
one of the biggest reasons social has
not been taken serious Enough by the
best creative agencies in the world is
because it's too hard not because it's
completely like I don't think it's cool
it's because it's harder it's a lot
easier to come up with a tagline and
make a video and put on TV what makes it
so hard the speed in which the consumer
attention is evolving the speed in which
the platforms are competing with each
other the real discipline of what we
call pack platforms and culture so on an
everyday basis understanding that today
Instagram cares more about its Carousel
ads and you need to make those versus a
regular post there's a level of being on
the pulse a day trading that most
agencies are not fast enough for they're
not built for that they're built for
briefs and meetings and pitching
thank you very much thank you I think
I've got everything amazing
foreign
[Music]
self-esteem is clear to me at this point
in life which is surround yourself with
more positive people surround yourself
with more positive noise you need to
understand that everything that comes
into your body like food from a
communication and energy standpoint is
affecting you and if you start hanging
out with people that want you to win you
will have more self-confidence if
someone's telling you you're beautiful
versus telling you you're ugly if
someone's telling you you're awesome
instead of you suck you're a different
person self-awareness is much harder the
only thing I've ever seen that's worked
is making people that know you the best
feel so safe when you ask them for
critical feedback just tell me what you
think and then also doing that with 10
people because you know that people have
different opinions and then if all 10 of
them say that you're a little lazy and
you don't see it there's probably a good
chance you're lazy awesome well thank
you very much Gary cheers I can't wait
to see all of you in Australia cheers
bye-bye see you soon
yeah
such a pleasure to be with all of you
how to effectively get senior clients to
understand the importance and also the
attention on social senior clients
really want to talk business not
marketing well that's what's worked for
us I only talk business one of the
reasons that social media is really
interesting to me is if you asked any
normal person that's smart to some
degree that in 2023 is it a good idea to
spend money on social media you'd have
to think that the person will say yes we
know what world we live in but there are
many clients we have that spend more
money on print than they do on social
that's insane the first question you
have to ask is how do you measure brand
that is the number one first question
and they're going to answer with a
report and then you got to ask them how
the data goes into the report and that's
where the conversation starts to get
interesting and so as you can imagine
now all of a sudden you're in a meeting
they're saying how do you measure this
and I go hey real quick before I explain
the ROI of social how is your Roi
metrics on your reporting looking for
last year great but why is your business
down 12 and then all sudden it
completely undermines the way they
measure and it changes everything thank
you everyone hope you have a great day
cheers
so much so nice to spend time
[Music]
life is what you decide it is the human
perspective is the Ultimate Weapon I
always say that you find what you're
looking for if you think the world sucks
good news turn on the television grab
your phone go on social media go pick up
a newspaper and in 20 minutes you will
see that the world sucks comma if you
decide the world is the best good news
turn on the television go grab the
newspaper go grab your phone and go on
social media and you can find that the
world is the best and I'm fascinated by
that variable anyway love you thank you
thank you very much thank you thank you
thank you
tomorrow
how are you very good thanks so much for
making the time I appreciate it it's
been great
yeah
the answers are always so not obvious
like the concept of accountability like
blaming feels like so counter-intuitive
to what we're trying to do it took me a
long time to understand what you were
saying
I get it brother the first couple times
I heard you talking about I was like oh
now that makes me feel like [__] correct
it's funny you say that because it's how
I learn how to say things too me knowing
that me talking about accountability
it's your fault wasn't Landing with a
majority was like okay what can I do
about this and and notice how somewhere
along the line like a year ago I would
say something like but that doesn't mean
that you suck right by adding that
that's not a bad thing it's a good thing
I have unwavering passion to help which
means it's going to come with some pain
it's your [__] fault who the [__]
wants to hear that
no one they will run away from that at
all costs
it's why it's the middle
it's balance
[Music]